I want to win I want to play serious I
want to be effective maybe God I am
lighting guy I need need you know to be
close to the guys we had they decided
that he will be the next coach of the
first team of Ibaka Barcelona and when I
told him this he said that you wouldn't
have the balls he's a Spanish
professional football coach former
player and current manager of Manchester
City as a manager he won 14 trophies in
the first four years of his managing
career he's considered by players
managers and commentators to be one of
the best managers in the world
he's Pep Guardiola and here is my take
on his top ten rules for success rule
number two is my personal favorite and
I'm curious if your girl which one you
guys like the best and as always if Pep
says something that really means
something to you please leave it in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
sophisticated magical intense motivator
calculated genius evolutionary
greatcoat
perfect job excellent perfectionist
obsessive passionate visionary babe
babies love
talking of talented players for any
young viewers out there who want to
become a professional footballer what
one bit of advice would you have for
them they have to look inside of
themselves if they have passion that's
all if they have passion they can do it
if they play just because it's always
going to be always it the big famous you
can go out with the beautiful girls or
win a lot of money that is no chance do
it do it do it not just about the photo
but I think about life if you like to do
something and you can spend thousand
million hours in that because you love
it all the professionals who stay a long
lunch and playing every three days in
important games because they love the
game
I think they don't love the game there's
a lot of training they can't stay for
long seems to be that manages well the
countries come and they are quickly
addicted to the place yeah have you
spoke to anybody on our behalf they told
me is so hard so tough and all the
people say pep is not going to adapt in
that good in that way so that's why I'm
here to try to to do it so the people
have some of them confident it's going
well but some of them are in Germany as
well the people say the way you play is
not be possible here in the Premier
League so and I said myself why not why
we don't travel there to try it and
that's why so it's a big challenge not
just for me but I am I was in in my team
so I was able to emboss the players and
it's going to happen here as well when
that's happened everything will be easy
you've said you are obsessive about
build up play in order to get results
would you sacrifice that at all
impossible it's impossible we sacrifice
for what reason would you lose a game if
you believe in that you have to keep
going so when when it's going to happen
when to use the goalkeeper going to a
wrong path and you're going to receive a
goal and the people say why you don't
hit ball no we have to in season that
the reason why why you miss that pass so
you wouldn't what we call win ugly play
maybe not attractive if it means you're
going to get away no no no no I will win
so the people say no is it when your
period build up or try to no I want to
win I want to play serious I want to be
effective I don't do that to to be I
want to play build up no I make a build
up to convince the players but that is
you have more consequence positive than
negative
if I believed in you that and it's not
productive for the team I will not do
that but I was a football player manager
and always when I did that I was caught
out of Gaza consi to you and that's what
I believe in
so it's attracted back with purpose hey
of course we're gonna win because not
city's going to to fire me if you were
to win the trophy again at Wembley you
feel he would have come full circle
yeah and never never thought to play in
verse when I was a boy and I was thought
to win a Champions League never thought
and became a coach never thought you
before to win a league championship and
now to try to beat one of the best teams
of the world in this atmosphere in
Wembley for us it's a dream come true
you say that or we read that you say
that you only really stay anywhere for
three or four years do you intend to
build a legacy here or at least what the
foundations they k9 they came to learn
you come to learn yeah of course that's
why I move on I came to let you know
there will be a still in Barcelona what
is the biggest challenge you face now
what is at the top of your to-do list
play good play good
and after trying to win one game and
after second one and after another one
but the first target is team spirit in
play good as as much as possible and
after try to win one game and after the
second one three years from now when you
threatened to leave and we have to tie
you to a chair and we won't let you
leave I will take your passport off you
what does success look like three years
from now for Manchester City yeah for
that you know for that for the for the
people for the media is how many titles
are you into in okay you will have
success or not success that is pretty
sure so but at the end the title is
amazing you leave the title and two days
after the people say what's next I think
the process is how we'll be comfortable
here working with these guys the end my
life depends on that I will be happy
when my relation with them and when we
decide to play in that way it works or
it doesn't work on that is at the end
because I am pretty sure the club will
be fantastic and the people the people
working with they're going to help me
and I am pretty sure that's going to
happen happen in person happen in Munich
and it's going to happen here and of
course I'm going to work the dough to
fight every day to live to win the
titles been especially from the people
when after the game will finish the game
so oh 90 minutes it was not bad I would
prefer to be here and not in the bar
that was a good sign oh and after the
relation with the people I think I may
because I am lighting guy I need need
you know to be close to the guys - to
hack - area to say I'm going to kill you
and five minute later - you know - love
each other I think I need that to be
happy and I hope in that's three years
that is going to happen we went to a
restaurant in Barcelona to talk
personally we had the
sided that he will be the next coach of
the first team of Baku Barcelona and
when I told him this he said that you
wouldn't have the balls you have because
he comes from the first division and at
the same time he said remember you know
that with me as a coach you will win
everything and it happened
balladeer L open timber sale he's cut
the Pendergast porque una persona can
Meza and turn at a mini Estadi the copy
holder Tom bass and say milk sauce is he
your prestige item barsa pero once
winery Skybus root K by M sin to for
tension to cast a despotic a Tripta yo
creo Mukasey Nocenti s nostaria case
Abood lequip Orellana visto preocupado
legend core our asses for Sarah
Yossi Purdue Rica Carol inserting an OG
per dune oregano sauce for SEMA show no
we knew that was a very tough decision
but you know we are taking this decision
with enthusiasm and with the expectation
that would be a great decision the
reality was much more better than our
expectations
she been a part of
don't try to fight a bit
killing me right now
thank God my mom
because we don't know
Oh
oh yeah
but Sarah sorry better witness feelings
I
we're not happy here
I can meet your name
Oh
Oh
it
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because David Kezi asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did peps say
that had the biggest meaning for you
what struck a chord what change you're
going to make in your life for business
after watching this video leave in the
comments I'm going to join in the
discussion finally want to give a quick
shout out to Steve inscriber from
scriber law calm Stephen thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book it
really really really means a lot to me
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon